among nato allies in europe there is a
feeling of deja vu the looming threat of
an afghan exodus recalls the influx of
more than a million refugees in 2015
most fleeing war in syria many even then
from afghanistan it was a movement of
people that reverberated politically
strengthening right-wing support across
the continent the direst consequence of
the taliban takeover of afghanistan for
europe now would be a repeat
the destabilization of afghanistan risks
causing irregular migration to europe
france as i've said has and will
continue to do its duty for those who
are most threatened but afghans in times
to come will need to muster their
strength europe cannot shelter the
consequences alone
calls for humanitarian corridors and a
coordinated european response by the
likes of emmanuel macron and the
outgoing german chancellor angela merkel
are likely to meet resistance from some
countries
greece has warned against again becoming
the gateway to europe austria plans to
continue deporting failed asylum seekers
back to afghanistan eu foreign ministers
meeting to discuss the crisis are
nowhere near consensus we have to ensure
that the new political situation created
in afghanistan
by the return of the talibans
does not lead to a large-scale migratory
movement over zero much will depend on
the willingness of transit countries
like turkey to contain the flow as it
eventually did in 2016 after a deal that
cost the eu three and a half billion
dollars
whether afghans stay or flee in far
greater numbers will depend on the
taliban and i would like
to ask as a woman please
don't recognize the immigrant islamic
taliban without any condition and don't
put us against the same situation thank
you very much
there's precious little anyone else can
do it was extremely difficult to make
the decision to end the nato military
presence in afghanistan and it was
difficult because i share your pain
nato's 20-year mission in afghanistan
has ended in failure european alliance
members can do little more now than
watch and wait for what comes next joe
nahul al jazeera